rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
partir dans le sud sauvage à la
découverte de la coulée du piton
takamaka en passant par le sentier du
tremblay pour votre santé
parcourez nos sentiers
depuis le village du tremblay au bord du
grand brûlé une variante du gr 2 permet
de monter jusqu'au volcan par le nez
coupé du tremblay par cet itinéraire il
est aussi possible de bifurquer vers le
piton de takamaka pour ensuite
redescendre le long de la coulée de 1986
ce sentier du tremblay sauvage et peu
fréquenté monte régulièrement au travers
d'une forêt dense le long de la rabine
pour rouge
ouvrez l'oeil car on peut y observer de
nombreuses orchidées
oui mais
sur cette montée de 1100 mètres de
dénivelé la progression est souvent
difficile
le sol est enchevêtrée deux racines les
marches sont parfois raid
b
le
mais l'effort vaut le coup surtout quand
on l'a vu se dégage sur la côte
magnifique
à mesure que l'on monte la végétation
change et devient plus basse un signe
encourageant qui indique bientôt la fin
de cette rude montée c'est maintenant
l'arrivée à l'ancien abri du tremblay
qui permettait aux randonneurs de faire
une halte sur la route du volcan mais
qui a été démantelé il ya deux ans
c'était un refuge avec eux le strict
minimum donc c'était quand même quelque
chose d'assez sommaire malheureusement
on a pris la décision de démonter ce
refuge parce que c'est vrai que les gens
vont y laisser quand même pas mal
d'ordures donc ça attire lra est donc le
rat est vecteur de maladie et donc pas
très accueillant et puis le refus jeter
aussi victime de deux dégradations
volontaires
donc on démonte et le mobilier l'état
mais bon même les portes et volets tout
ça pour faire du feu que les gens il
arrivait donc en voyant l'état du refuge
bailly s'y arrêtait pas quoi
depuis l'ancien abri on quitte le
sentier qui monte jusqu'au volcan pour
bifurquer plein sud à flanc de falaise
ce sentier en faux-plat traversée de
plusieurs ravine est également assez
difficile avec certains passages
techniques
dans leurs deux souhaits
je suis d'un soir
quand la redescente s'amorce au milieu
des brandes que la qualité du sol change
et que la vue se dégage à nouveau
c'est signe que nous sommes arrivés au
sommet de la coulée de 1986 là je me
trouve en plein milieu de la fissure de
la colique de 1986 en fait là c'est
vraiment une faille sur une très longue
distance qui s'est ouverte
donc ça a été provoquée par la remontée
du magma en surface et c'est par ces
fissures que sont sortis les coulées de
lave alors les éruptions or en cours ne
sont pas les plus fréquentes
heureusement parce que en rang clos ça
veut dire aussi qu'ils à des villages en
contrebas donc ça il ya des risques
quand même dans 86 les habitants ils ont
été au courant parce qu'ils ont vu de la
lave qui devenait de la montagne donc en
espérant qu'en 2013-2014 soit un peu
plus équipés pour être informé un peu
plus rapidement les européens n'en peut
en avoir oui à nouveau et à n'importe
quel moment
la redescente s'effectue ensuite le long
de la coulée en dessous du piton
takamaka qui lui a donné son nom il n'en
est pourtant pas à l'origine puisqu'il
est beaucoup plus vieux et que les
fissures se sont ouvertes bien au dessus
de lui sur le gratton la végétation
encore très jeune et constituer des
espèces pionnières des fougères des
lichens des bois de rempart de chaque
côté de la coulée la forêt originelle
séculaire semble narguer ses espèces qui
doivent lutter contre un autre fléau les
espèces exotiques
la traversée d'un chemin goudronné
indique enfin que la route n 2 n'est
plus très loin sur laquelle débouche le
sentier à trois kilomètres de notre
point de départ et c'est la fin de notre
randonnée à ski et bien ça c'est
randonnée c'est cette diversité de
paysages qu'on traverse au fur et à
mesure de notre cheminement
donc on a débuté dans une forêt
anthropisés et puis ensuite plus on
monte plus on monte dans les indigènes
dans l'endémique donc les forêts de bois
de couleur des eaux on retrouve plein
d'orchidées comme on est en fin de fin
d'année donc c'est là où le plus grand
nombre d'heures qu'ils y sont en fleurs
donc les engrais comme essilor keith
donc certaines qui sont rares d'autres
beaucoup plus communes
et puis comme je suis passionné aussi
par la photo par la macro donc j'en
profite pour faire essayer de faire de
belles photos
c'est une rando assez longue
enfin qu'il faut s'y préparer en avance
arrivez tôt pour pouvoir bénéficier du
beau temps et puis savoir qu'on va
partir sur la journée quoi bien se
renseigner sur les sur les conditions
météo sur les temps de parcours la
difficulté des sentiers pas mal de
paramètres à prendre en compte avant de
de s'aventurer sur ce genre de sentiers